were you making money at it like eight
i started making money when i was
probably like
i mean yeah i did a couple like little
like game show
like cause i'm like what does an
eight-year-old buy with a [ __ ] load of
money are you like i have a million
pieces of bubble gum or like yeah
no no man that's how much of a
skateboard i was anything i made i spent
at the skate shop
oh wow yeah i wanted boards and i wanted
new helmets and you know i wanted i
wanted all of it
i got a board for you bro i know i'm
stuck
signed and everything yeah but i bought
like things
kids want you know like i bought remote
control cars and like i would buy my
brother remote control car and like i
i liked video like toys and bikes yeah
like a bike i got a really cool like red
line bicycle i
like i remember getting bicycles and
skateboards and just like toys man it
was all
toys it was fun dude it was fun yeah
[ __ ]
what up what like what kind of crazy
cars have you had
uh crazy cars man
when i was 18 i bought a ferrari uh 4
30.
that thing was fun super fun
had three how fast have you gone in it
in the ferrari i only went about 150.
the thing was so close to the ground and
it was so
like it was so violent and the the
shifting was just violent it was
actually kind of scary
it's kind of a scary car um so you kept
it at a modest 150
[Laughter]
yeah yeah about about buck 50 in that
thing but
my favorite cars have been the uh the
s65
uh the amg mercedes benz i've had three
of those things and man
they are that they're rocket ships dude
for a four door sedan it's a rocket ship
and my last one i had i tuned it up and
it was pushing out
a little over 800 horsepower and hit 176
miles an hour in that thing and it was
like
where wild pico no not on pico no
just headed down south so crazy dude
but yeah it's a quick blast you know but
that car is crazy because the faster you
go the more the suspension
lowers the car and the steering gets
tighter it's like it's race car
that's sick but it's four-door you know
it's it's a sleeper definitely a sleeper
yeah dude